[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia good guy
remember it so you don't have to it's no
secret the dr. Seuss films have had a
bit of a checkered past dirty ho Taco
Bell pretty goddamn bad apparently but
the one film that everyone agrees is
good least bad is horton hears a who
starring Jim Carrey and Steve Carell
because that works so great before the
film was based on the hit book that led
to an underperforming box-office
overtime though it's gotten the
reputation as the closest thing to a
good dr. Seuss movie we ever got well
I'm here to ask is it really I mean
granted we all know Suze needs more
anime references emo kids and whatever
the hell this is but is it good enough
to count as a decent movie or is it just
the least thing well I think it's time
to look over what was ironically
overlooked of them about being
overlooked
so let's look it over this is my review
of horton hears a who
it starts off pretty enough with a
colorful and creative environment as Jim
Carrey thank God not covered in makeup
to look like the character at this time
he's teaching a class of ugly about the
various animals in the forest yeah it's
definitely movement your kitchen like
that then a sour kangaroo played by
Carol Burnett looks over the shenanigans
Horton is causing why can't I play with
the other kids mom the jungle is no
place to act like a wild animal she'll
learn to lighten up and he'll be happy
can we just get that 1/3 of the movie
now but that tiny speck flies by and
horton hears a sound from it the
animation cleverly goes hand-drawn to
show Hortons imagination mimicking
Seuss's original style but unfortunately
the rest of the style seems to like
action and references for the sake of
they're just being action of references
but lots of smaller bananas in the lorry
I feel the diplomatic process is
beginning to break down it's just like
Robin Williams in Aladdin except he came
in halfway through the film so we could
get to know the characters and this
hasn't even been 9 minutes yet horton
catches the speck on a flower but the
kangaroo is not amused
no really she sounds like that there
aren't people that's small what if there
was someone way out there looking down
on our world right now there is nothing
on that speck as an atheist it's my job
to be offended by that and then offended
by anyone else being offended by
anything but sure enough there's a whole
town of people on a speck filled with
people called the whose steve carell
plays the mayor named the man named Mick
dog wait what the dog wait what
look dog make God look dog Nick God
mcdhh on whatever you just call him that
to rhyme with odd was devoted and fair
and a little bit odd apparently who
spurned come out of shotgun barrel
testicles because the mayor has 96
daughters and I'm gonna take a wild
guess and say his wife would not look
that good after so many births I think
this will be a more fitting
representation there is however one boy
in the group he's the oldest named Joe
Joe who the mayor is prepping to take
over as mayor but he never speaks
because get this and why didn't he speak
well I think the lad was afraid if he
did he might let down his dad clearly
you understand why many children also
don't speak you may catch a psychology
book dr. Seuss
says people meanwhile Horton comes
across his friend Seth Rogen yeah they
named this character something else but
listen to it that's awesome Lauren that
really helps even if I said the
character's name all you would hear as
Seth Rogen watch Seth Rogen see he tells
Horton to keep the speck to himself but
Hortons students I think the whole
teacher thing never comes back with
Horton accidentally get him to blurt it
out
however Hortons movements are causing
big earthquakes in the whose world
because they all of this somehow had no
impact
however this disturbs the mayor who
suggests postponing their big whose
celebrations they of course don't listen
to him nearing the rejection Horton is
going for as well but it seems to who's
just want to ignore the problem and
spend their time on who
space yeah you see why topical jokes
don't always work Seuss movies important
and the mayor finally hear each other
and they try to explain who / what / who
they are your whole world fits on a
flower in my world it's pretty amazing
and if you don't want me to go astronaut
from Twilight Zone on your ass you'll
and the sounds like fun
realizing the danger they could be and
the mayor as Horton to locate them a
safer spot to be placed
Horton decides to put them at the top of
a mountain because those are safe as
hell but he decides to do it once again
through hand-drawn animation oh cool you
mean like in Seuss's original style like
what you did before our South Park just
made fun of anime at the time I guess we
can - it is clear that you are no match
for a DK I think this calls for a
facepalm with a facepalm you have
asteroid but the kangaroo has my game I
will make monkeys of these cookies it is
their destiny dr. Susan watch anime is
there a crunchy rhyme thank you please
never anything again finally we can get
the story back on track give me a break
I need a break here's a break
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so Horton trusses a shaky bridge to get
to the mountain as once again Hortons
movement seemed to only affect the
environment around the mayor you know
Carol Burnett is in this race she won't
like that we're ripping her off he makes
it across the bridge and seems to be
very happy I feel really good right now
maybe it's my new sense of purpose you
[Music]
know for a new sense of purpose he sure
does seem to do a lot of stuff with no
purpose
the kangaroo hates that Hortons
imagination is spreading to the children
so she decides to send a giant vulture
after him I would only do this for a
price this little kangaroo
mommy's thinking it over I'm so glad
she's fighting for the children by
debating whether or not she wants to
sacrifice her own to a vulture with that
that seemed bizarrely out of character
she can be mean but not give up her kid
mean I mean don't get me wrong she still
says no but what I think more sense if
she was insulted by that gesture she
seems to just smile and walk away
forcing him to change his tune in fact
even for his character it doesn't really
fit he's constantly trying to look scary
but it's revealed he's not as
threatening as he appears in fact he's
kind of us grew up so why was this
pointless moment of two characters
breaking character even in here it
doesn't seem to add anything it's not
very funny and it doesn't match their
personas I mean it makes about as much
sense as having boy yeah that's right
they just like pointless isn't that
sad bill mmm-hmm
the vulture attacks Horton resulting in
one of my favorite jokes in the movie
hoo-hoo
I just know he's gonna jump out
somewhere yellow I can't no but I like
it when the movie critiques as cliches
before I do he manages to fight him off
but the town finally notices that
is happening resulting in the
politicians high up saying nothing is
wrong you sure this is fiction
the mayor finally tells everybody what's
going on hey
giant elephant in the sky don't bother
looking he's invisible would it sound
better if it was a turtle it was written
by Stephen King
they obviously don't believe them there
and the flower is taken away before he
can prove Horton is really around like
in the book it's dropped into a gigantic
field of flowers making it impossible to
find and exactly like the book he finds
it I never said the book was flawless
the who is finally here Horton which
allows him to do his best John F Kennedy
impersonation and we will put us back on
mountain or before the end of this
decade
this is JFK and dr. Seuss too you know
if there's a who Christ why am i
questioning anything
the kangaroo finds out though and tries
to rally everybody behind her this is
Horan we're talking about you all know
him
he wouldn't hurt a fly except for that
fly City he sat on but he didn't do that
on purpose
huh so in this version horton already
killed a town of tiny living things the
crowd rushes towards Horton to take the
speck away from him so all the Hoos
tried to scream to be heard this leads
to a musically and visually creative
climax resulting in all the various
noises they can make
[Music]
[Applause]
sure enough Jojo just happened to create
a device in his off time to make the
loudest noise in town yeah and Jojo of
course sounds off the final sound
speaking for the first time breaking the
sound barrier I don't know but the
animals finally hear it and the
Kangaroos son saves them and brings the
flower back to Horton
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah there's punk rockin dr. Seuss - I
don't care
Horton apparently is nice enough to even
forgive the kangaroo
[Music]
it's the least I can do for attempting
mass genocide what are we gonna do
without you Horton I'll always be around
oh and in the last five minutes we
decided to become a musical because our
identities now strong enough to say we
shouldn't we zoom out and see a whole
universe of beautiful specks and this
butt ugly thing what do you know what's
the joke with that don't tell me I don't
want to see it again
Orton here's a who I hear a
middle-of-the-road shrug the bad stuff
isn't nearly as bad as the other Seuss
films and once in a while there is a
funny and/or creative moment but it
tries too hard to hit too many
demographics resulting in a weak
experience but not necessarily a bad one
it's not painful it's just kind of
confused you can feel the pressure from
Studios producers and what have you
trying to make this something distinct
and instead turning out something kind
of underwhelming still I think kids can
watch it fine there's no real bad
lessons in it at least if you don't
think too hard about them I guess in
hindsight it is the best dr. Seuss movie
ever made but given his other films
that's not exactly a high bar it is what
it is a middle-of-the-road flick and
compared to the other Seuss films I'll
gladly take that any day
I'm a nostalgia critic I remember it so
you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing BRC
BRC is a leading provider of housing and
services to thousands of New York City's
medius individuals offering a hand up
not a handout BRC sees the potential in
each individual it serves and provides
each the opportunity to find it BRC has
a 24/7 outreach to homeless people
living in public spaces drug treatment
mental healthcare comprehensive medical
services and supportive communities in
which to live more than 5200 times in a
year an individual in need said yes to
BRC
and walk through their doors and over
3,000 times a BRC client successfully
graduated and moved forward to reclaim
their life if you look at their site or
their YouTube channel you can hear all
the stories of people this wonderful
organization helped click on the link
and see how you can help somebody find a
new beginning
you
[Music]